>>Ian Lewis: (Off mike.)
>>Dan Galpin: I think there are about two
people who got --
>>Ian Lewis: Everyone in the front row got
that joke.
The rest of you, doesn't matter.
[ Applause ]
>>Dan Galpin: It's not a very Googley joke,
though, as they go.
I guess we're going to go with half of a screen.
>>Ian Lewis: People on the right side of the
room, sorry, man.
Sorry.
>>Dan Galpin: Now we need volume off of that,
believe it or not.
Ooh, that's good.
>>Ian Lewis: Oh, no.
That one's better.
Here.
(Sound effects).
>>Dan Galpin: There we are.
Each week, deep in their secret chambers below
Google building 44, the Android editorial
board meets to decide which apps and games
will be featured in the Google Play Store.
This is an important decision.
For a lot of developers, it's a matter of
life and death.
So we take it very seriously.
>>Ian Lewis: At the same time, it is an editorial
decision.
What does that mean?
You have no control over this.
I have no control over this.
The -- my wife wants to call me, but that's
not going to happen.
[ Laughter ]
>>Dan Galpin: The one time you're allowed
to say "no."
>>Ian Lewis: Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: You can't pay for featuring in
Google Play.
You can't bribe people.
You can't send us bottles of Dom Perignon
and then get featured.
That actually doesn't work as well as some
people seem to think.
>>Dan Galpin: But keep trying.
>>Ian Lewis: There's no sure-fire recipe for
getting featured.
The decision is made by the editorial team
according to their own criteria.
So you're never going to see a talk called,
"What to do to get featured on Google Play."
At the same time, Dan and I have spent a lot
of time with the editorial board, and we've
seen a lot of games, a lot of excellent games,
get rejected for what seem like sort of minor
reasons.
A lot of them are problems that are really
easy to fix.
So although we can't talk about what to do
to get featured on Google Play, we can talk
about what to not do to not not not get featured
on not --
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: -- not -- yeah.
Anyway --
>>Dan Galpin: The transcription is going to
be great there.
>>Ian Lewis: More succinctly, ten things that
every Android gamer developer should know.
So let's start with number one, Dan.
>>Dan Galpin: All right.
So one of the things that people do when they
go out and buy their great new Android handset
is they come back and go to Google Play, and
they want to get great stuff.
And, you know -- that was good -- we at Android
love all your releases, but we always have
a special place in our heart for our newest
version and we love it when people use our
newest operating system.
We also love it when people buy now Android
devices.
So we tend to avoid featuring anything that's
incompatible with the latest and greatest.
The first thing you want to do is make sure
you support high resolutions.
You'll need to author your assets today for
at least 720p.
And remember that not all 720p displays are
equal.
Assets that look great on a ten-inch tablet
aren't necessarily going to work on a seven-inch
tablet or phone.
And this is especially true for UI elements
that have to be sized like your fingers, like
drumsticks.
>>Ian Lewis: Oh, Dan, tell them what the dpi
the Nexus 7 is.
>>Dan Galpin: So the Nexus 7 is in between.
But you should really think of it for the
most part as being an hdpi device.
We refer to it as tvdpi.
And what this means is, don't expect to have
a resource that's sized for your finger.
Instead, look at the display density and scale
your resources accordingly.
>>Ian Lewis: Because you do not want to be
the guy that designs the Xbox one controller;
right?
I've seen tablet games that basically do that.
>>Dan Galpin: Another thing you want to make
sure is do -- make sure your app isn't running
compatibility mode on Honeycomb and above.
You can tell you're in compatibility mode
because there will be extra icons in your
status bar like the menu button.
Not everyone knows what this means, but to
experienced users, it's a red flag.
So what can you do about it?
It turns out the solution is very simple.
Just specify a target API of 11 or above.
The target API for what reason is called target
SDK version in your application manifest and
you should really target the latest version
as much as possible.
All that really means is I have tested on
the latest version of Android.
And this is good, because we won't turn on
any compatibility shims.
>>Ian Lewis: Now, the compiler will give you
a warning.
It will say, hey, you just specified a target
SDK that's greater than your min SDK, like
that's a problem.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, yeah.
So that's the one time -- Normally, look at
Lint and be, like, "Yes, Lint is right."
In this case, --
>>Ian Lewis: Don't believe its lies.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah.
Lint will actually do the right thing and
it will actually tell you if you use API levels
that aren't going to work on your target devices.
So it's good.
A lot of programmers worry that specifying
a high-target API is going to mean it gets
filtered out on the Play Store.
Of course, that isn't the case.
It's just designed to turn off compatibility
shim.
Filtering is done with min and max SDK version.
And, in general, it makes sense to send min
SDK version to the lowest version that your
game will run on, set target SDK version to
the version of the SDK you're compiling against
or testing against, and really don't ever
set max SDK version.
But you know what's cooler than API level
16?
Lights out.
You can almost completely hide the soft buttons.
And this is really easy to do.
Just, literally, take -- go to your view and
set your view to status bar hidden.
You can only do this on Honeycomb and above.
The good news is that it's very easy to put
in a conditional around that, as long as you're,
you know, not targeting Donut or something
like that.
>>Ian Lewis: Right.
They told us by the way to put a code sample
in for that and we're like, these --
>>Dan Galpin: They don't need a code sample
for that.
>>Ian Lewis: We'll be posting code sample
later.
So thing number two, how to evade pirates
and symptom vampires.
So by "pirates" and "vampires," we mean people
who steal software and people who steal bandwidth
by downloading game (indiscernible) resources
when they haven't actually bought your game.
Now, we can go on and on about whether pirates
represent lost sales or theoretical lost sales
or a wonderful new distribution mechanism
that's going to make us all rich.
But of the two, vampires are the ones we're
most concerned about, because they represent
an immediate bill to you for bandwidth that
you're using to download assets that were
never paid for.
So we want to stop vampires the most, but
we do want to stop them both.
When we're talking about stopping pirates,
a lot of times we talk about copy protection.
There's one thing that you should never do.
And that is check the copy protection box
on the Google Play publisher site.
We had this thing when we were sort of young
and naive as an operating system called forward-locking.
And it prevented users from casually copying
APKs from phone to phone.
We optimistically called it copy protection
because we thought that it would help to curb
piracy.
It turns out we were completely wrong.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: Forward-locking doesn't actually
stop piracy at all.
It's supposed to keep users from copying games.
But what it really does is prevents the completely
legitimate activity of putting a game on the
SD card.
But it gets better.
Not only does forward-locking prevent you
from moving to SD card, but it also expands
the size of the APK on your internal storage.
So you basically have got the worst of both
worlds if you check that box.
If you did ever check it, go uncheck it now.
Just remember that once you remove forward-locking,
you will have to do another APK upload to
get that update to come out.
We're actually removing it very soon, because
it turned out to be a bit of what they call
a Charlie Foxtrot in the business.
So what do you do?
Well, first, in order to deter pirates, you
should use the license verification library.
Now, this isn't a perfect solution.
But it will help to deter casual piracy.
It will not stop the most determined hackers.
For vampires, though, we have an extremely
good solution.
It's already saved many of our partners hundreds
of thousands of dollars in bandwidth.
And that is APK expansion files, which means
that Google is hosting your large files for
you instead of you having to use your own
content distribution network.
This is good for two reasons.
First, no cost to you.
Second, unless you're a very, very large company
yourself, we probably have a better CDN than
you do.
So faster and cheaper.
Use APK expansion files.
You can also, if you do want to serve your
own files, watch Dan's presentation from last
year's Google I/O to understand how to tie
large file downloads to the LVL, license verification
library.
That's actually what the APK expansion system
does internally.
And you can do it externally as well.
Large file hosting is available now.
It works on almost everything.
And for the devices that were unable to get
the Google Play update that enables large
files, you can download Dan's excellent shim
library that is chockful of best practices
for how to do a background download, and you'll
find that your user experience for downloads
is much, much better.
>>Dan Galpin: Thank you.
So now to point 3, which is don't mess with
the buttons.
And as you noticed, these Android devices
have buttons on them, things like the lock
button and the volume button and the back
button and the home button and the, you know,
app switcher button.
And, basically, the goal with most of these
is -- is either leave it alone because you
can't do anything about it, or try to use
the default behavior of the framework.
In the case of the volume keys, you want to
make sure those volume messages go to the
framework so you actually get the normal popup
that the user expects for controlling the
volume.
Now, the one real question that game developers
have is, what do I do about the back button?
Because most games actually consist of a single
activity.
And the default behavior for the back button
is just to close, destroy the activity, and
remove history.
So the way we like to think of the back button
is it's sort of like the escape key.
So let's take our example game here.
And, you know, basically, you know, this is
-- you know, this is a simple arcade game.
And we start the game.
We go through a few menus.
We're in the middle of our playing.
And we hit the back key.
And, boom, what does that do?
Well, it makes sense for it to take us back
here, because that's what the user expects;
right?
That's the screen the user was on.
Even though this was all a single activity,
we expect the Android navigation paradigm
to be, you know, used.
So another option is to actually pop up a
dialogue.
And this is very common.
A lot of game developers do this.
It's not the best practice because it really
doesn't match the Android navigation paradigm.
But it's very well known, and we certainly
don't have anything against this practice.
So the real question now is, you put up this
dialogue.
And where do you want it to go after you hit
the back key again?
Do you want it to go back to this screen?
Or do you want it to go back to the game play?
And, really, if -- since this one is obviously
looking like a dialogue, we expect it to behave
like a dialogue in Android.
We pop the dialogue in the back key, and we
expect it to be dismissed.
In general, what we're talking about here
is choosing the UI that will disrupt the user's
game experience the least.
So dismissing the pause menu like a dialogue
actually will be what the user expects.
But even better again, we skip the pause menu
entirely, go back to our previous screen.
We have some very obvious option to allow
the user to continue where they left off.
>>Ian Lewis: Now, I realize that this is an
incredible mockup and you're probably thinking,
okay, I want my game to look exactly like
that.
But the truth is, Dan and I made it in Photoshop
and we're not professionals.
So you might want to steer clear.
But the main point that we're --
>>Dan Galpin: Are you saying we don't have
elite design skills?
>>Ian Lewis: No.
No, we don't.
The main point is that you want to be able
to go back to a previous UI screen, but always
have a way to go forward again.
>>Dan Galpin: Exactly.
And here's the thing really, really not to
do.
And there's a lot of reasons why this is bad.
One that, obviously, this is a system dialogue
which drops the user out of their game.
It's better than just quitting without warning,
admittedly, you know, because at least the
user hasn't lost data and lost the state here.
But not by much.
It -- just don't do it.
So here is our back button recap.
And believe it or not, there have been internal
discussions about this, and debates.
>>Ian Lewis: Ad nauseam.
>>Dan Galpin: Yes, exactly.
But this is the basic theory of back button
in Android games.
In a dialogue, dismiss the dialogue.
In a UI, whenever possible, move to previous
screen.
In game play, either pause or do one of the
following: Show an options dialogue, move
to the previous screen.
And make sure that they haven't lost any state.
And at the initial UI screen, you can just
dismiss the app.
There's no need to put up a big screen that
says, "Do you really want to quit?"
>>Ian Lewis: Do you really want to quit the
title screen?
This is an awesome title screen.
>>Dan Galpin: This is an epic title screen.
>>Ian Lewis: Exactly.
But the most important thing is, never lose
progress.
>>Dan Galpin: Never.
>>Ian Lewis: Never allow the user to lose
progress.
That would suck.
To a certain extent, that also means don't
lose progress in terms of needing to go back
and load for 30 seconds, which sometimes you
can't do much about.
All right.
Number 4, respect the life cycle.
We're going to illustrate the life cycle problem
with a little story.
So wake up early in the morning.
First thing I do is reach for my phone.
Can you get a little gaming in before work?
When I'm going to go to work and play for
games.
But let's pretend this isn't me.
This is some other dude.
So, right, on a roll.
Everything's cool.
Totally lost track of time.
Oh, no, I'm going to miss my bus.
So really quick, throw on my -- my work clothes,
which totally look like this, and jump on
the bus, head off to work.
Now I'm giving a presentation to my boss.
Everything's going well until I've got to
check something on my phone; right?
Exactly.
Pull that baby out.
Turn it on.
Oh, my God, what's going on here?
It's not just that it's playing music.
It's playing music and the phone is locked.
And now I'm really stressed out and I've got
this lengthy PIN code that I need to enter
and I can't even remember what it is; right?
So everything sucks, my boss thinks I'm more
of an idiot than he already did.
I've just ruined my whole day.
What's the problem here?
Well, the issue is that the life cycle here
is complicated.
Not only is it complicated, it's varying slightly
from OS to OS, none of the delivery order
that you're seeing here is guaranteed.
In fact, it is changed in Jelly Bean because
-- (Clap) -- we told them to.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: So the problem is, you lock your
phone, and the app gets an onpause.
And then it gets an onstop at some point.
When you -- and, actually, the really great
thing is, on Honeycomb and ICS, there were
some cases where while the phone was asleep,
you would get an onresume.
We didn't cover that here.
But sometimes that will happen.
Then the user goes back and presses the lock
button again and the phone tries to wake up
and sends the foreground app, an onrestart,
onresume.
Now, you might be thinking at this point,
who's the foreground app?
You would be justified in assuming that it's
the app in the foreground, which is the lock
screen.
Wrong.
It's actually your app because until Jelly
Bean, the lock screen didn't count as an application,
it was sort of a random overlay.
So what will happen is your application thinks
that it's woken up and starts, you know, playing
music or doing whatever, but it's actually
being hidden by the lock screen still, and
that's a really, really annoying behavior.
There's actually a very, very easy way to
fix this.
And forget about all this life cycle stuff
because it's difficult.
There are edge cases, it's incredibly annoying
to get right.
All you need to do is this: If your application's
paused, if your game is paused, stop playing
the sound.
And when you want to start playing sound again,
what do you look for?
Not some Android life cycle, you look for
the game getting unpaused which requires some
sort of user activity, right?
So the user hits a button to take you out
of pause and go back to game play, that's
when you restart the sound.
It turns out this is great for two reasons:
First, it avoids all this nonsense.
Second, it turns out it's a great user experience
to leave the app and then when you come back
in it's paused, so you don't just get thrown
right back into game play before you're prepared.
Of course, hitting lock screen isn't the only
way that your game can get paused or even
killed during game play.
This is a consequence of being on a mobile
operating system, right?
It's not about multitasking, it's not about,
you know, which model we chose or how we tombstone
or anything like that, it's just the fact
that your user is playing your game on a device
that's designed to let him know when important
things happen like a phone call comes in.
It's designed to be put in a pocket when he
needs to catch the bus.
Android, by its very nature, being a smartphone
OS, is interruptible, and so you need to be
completely prepared to handle those interruptions
in a way that doesn't waste your users' time.
So we said it before and we're going to recap
now -- never, ever, allow your user to lose
progress based on an interruption that's beyond
their control or even an interruption that's
under their control.
Should we go to thing five?
>>Dan Galpin: Exactly, all right, so Ian,
this is your chance to get on the synthesizer
here.
Just want you to know we're using an FM synthesizer
that is unfortunately -- there we are, we
needed some volume.
This is an open source project, so you're
more than welcome to download it and Ian is
going to give me some nice -- that's good,
all right.
[ Music ]
>>Ian Lewis: Howdy-doo, Dan!
>>Dan Galpin: So minimize permissions.
This is an actual application on Google Play.
This is actually the list of permissions that
the user has to see.
[ Laughter ]
>>Dan Galpin: And, you know, like, what is
the user going to be like, gee, what am I
agreeing to?
Okay.
That is actually from the web interface.
So what we have now is our top ten bad game
permissions.
Yes, this is a top ten list inside of a top
ten list.
>>Ian Lewis: By the way, you can tell that
this is a Dan Galpin slide deck because we
used the fire effect more than once.
Totally broke that rule.
[ Laughter ]
>>Dan Galpin: Number one bad -- Number 10
-- excuse me -- bad permission for a game
to have is change Wi-Fi settings.
Why are you doing this?
You're turning -- you're toggling Wi-Fi on
and you have no idea whether the user has
actually set up Wi-Fi and even better, there's
an intent to throw the user right into the
Wi-Fi chooser.
So don't do it.
Receive boot completed.
Okay, admittedly there are some games that
are resource management kind of games and
they really want to make sure they can constantly
set alarms, but in general most games don't
need to do this unless they're trying to spam
the user with something.
Just please don't do this unless you absolutely
have you have to.
Probably the only good use of actually starting
your game up is because you want to set an
alarm.
And that's pretty much it.
You want to make an alarm persist across a
boot.
Do very, very lightweight stuff here.
The real key thing is, whatever you do, do
not have a consistently running service that
makes a network connection and sucks the user's
battery down.
And we'll talk about that a little later.
>>Ian Lewis: Unless you're making a game for
me because I love it when my game notifies
me that my cow needs to be clicked, I would
forget to click that cow.
>>Dan Galpin: Yeah, absolutely.
Not to mention, it's really nice, it helps
to keep your hand warm as the phone's radio
is constantly being kept on in your pocket.
All right.
Query running tasks.
Why does a game want to spy other tasks?
There are a couple semi-legitimate reasons
for this, but most of the time, your game
doesn't need to know what other tasks are
running.
Obtain fine location.
Okay, now, there's a lot of people, like,
I have a location-based game, if you have
a location-based game, if your game actually
maybe has a change in it, if the user walks
into their local coffee shop, then, yeah,
obtain fine location is cool.
For most games, users are concerned with analytics,
they want to know approximately where people
are playing their game, they want to know
a little bit about the demographics of their
marketing.
Obtain fine location is just kind of creepy
and it requires firing up the GPS, using a
lot of battery.
Don't do it, course location is good enough.
>>Ian Lewis: A lot of people will come back
and tell us, well, my ad network required
that.
You know what, no.
Because, you know what, this guy does not
need different ads than that guy, all right?
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: This is not the way things work.
So course location is fine for that.
>>Dan Galpin: Read system log.
Now, I've got bad news for you guys.
If you haven't watched some of our other presentations,
read system log actually is gone as of J.
There is no more read system log that you
can get.
However -- however -- J allows you, without
a permission, to read the system log for your
own app.
All right?
C'mon, this is really cool stuff.
[ Applause ]
>>Dan Galpin: So the good news is no creepy
spying on what the user is doing by turning
on their read system log permission.
And at the same time you can still get to
the useful logs you need to help your debugging
if the crash recording and all the stuff we
have on Google Play isn't enough.
All right, directly call phone numbers.
We've seen this in a lot of applications.
I'm like, seriously, there's an intent.
Fire off and call a phone number.
Why would you actually use this permission?
That's just like -- like do you really want
the game to pop up something that directly
-- I don't get it.
All right.
Read and write contacts and calendar.
Now, admittedly, there are some uses, but
most of them, 99% of them can actually be
done with contact choosers and contact figures,
you don't actually need to have the contact
permission if you just want to have the user
fill in a name.
The only reason you need this is because you
need to do something like spam every single
user, or even worse, go and read their contacts
and suck them into your own service and use
them for nefarious purposes.
And remember, these are not things that we're
saying you can't use.
What we're saying is if you use these things,
you're going to really reduce your chance
of ever being featured.
Okay, so this is really the key thing about
this list is that we're going to take what
you're doing reading the user's contacts and
calendar, and unless you have a really, really
good excuse, we're not going to feature the
app.
That's what the team is going to do.
>>Ian Lewis: I just got a reminder, it's 9:30
a.m. Click cow.
>>Dan Galpin: Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
>>Dan Galpin: Reading and writing bookmarks.
Super creepy.
I want to go and check out --
>>Ian Lewis: This is eastern European porn
site stuff, people.
>>Dan Galpin: Do you really -- does a game
really want to know the sites that someone
else -- that's awful.
And writing to the bookmarks is even worse.
Like wait, where is that super annoying site
and how did it get to my -- so, you know,
look, unless you have a -- I can't think of
a legitimate reason for using this, which
is why it's number three, but you're going
to have to justify it seriously to the editorial
board if you want to get a game featured with
that.
Display system level alerts.
This is the way you make your app do creepy
stuff and pop up on top of other applications.
And it's just not good.
There's a very, very good chance your game
has no possible useful way of doing this.
Use the notification system we have built
into Android.
That's what it's for.
And then finally, our number one top ten bad
permission that is likely to get you not featured
is send and receive SMS.
[ Applause ]
>>Dan Galpin: And first of all, so receive
SMS really sucks because it actually allows
your app to filter every single SMS message
that comes into the device.
Awful, awful, awful.
As a user, I'm like no way am I downloading
that app.
Okay?
And then send SMS, well, that allows you to
bill people without them knowing that, isn't
that awesome?
So, yeah, seriously, if you ever want to get
featured and this is there, I mean, like the
chances are basically zero.
But there is a way, if you really want to
allow the user to share to all their friends
over SMS, use the intent.
There's no permission involved and the users
will thank you.
All right, so there we are, our top ten list
of bad permissions for games to not get featured
on Google Play.
>>Ian Lewis: All right.
[ Applause ]
>>Ian Lewis: And we're only half done, folks.
But we did sort of front-load this thing because
we thought you'd all be gone by this point.
So item six, ready?
There is no item six.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: Like two guys got that.
Why did you do the hat?
That's so unfair, you upstaged me with your
Cruella De Vil pimp hat.
>>Dan Galpin: Hey, it was Pride last weekend
here in San Francisco, okay, they were selling
these all over the streets.
>>Ian Lewis: Pretty amazing.
>>Dan Galpin: And it does say on my I/O tag
"wears funny hats," there we are.
>>Ian Lewis: Good point.
Well, actually, we brought out the funny hat
because -- yeah, this is the boring, freaky
part.
We're in San Francisco, Dan drives a Prius.
>>Dan Galpin: You know, not everyone needs
to know that.
There are at least two or three Google employees
who do not drive Priuses.
>>Ian Lewis: That's true, I drive a '95 Integra
that doesn't pass emissions.
That's the kind of guy I am.
Environmental policy aside, it's important
to be green on your app on the phone.
It's important to conserve your users' resources.
You're game developers, you want to make the
coolest game possible, you want to monetize
and do some analytics and drive engagement,
but these are portable devices, they have
limited capabilities, they have limited resources.
Your battery, your network bandwidth, your
memory and storage are all precious, precious
commodities that your users try to maximize
at all times.
And because users try to maximize these, we
give them tools to understand what's going
on.
And if you haven't already, you will find
that users use these tools all the time and
they watch your game.
And if your battery usage is high, if you're
always on the network, if you've got long-running
services in the background, they will find
out and they will publicly shame you off and
on Google+.
APK expansion files.
See, what will happen is Google Play drops
your APK expansion on the SDK card, which
is cool, and then a lot of people say, you
know what, I actually had that all packed
up into one file because the man wouldn't
let me upload more than two files.
So I'm going to go ahead and unpack that so
that I can actually use it.
Oh, but then, wait, I've just used up a bunch
more storage so my policy's going to be let's
delete the original APK expansion file.
That seems like it would make a lot of sense,
but it does not, three times, you see?
See, we're so bad.
The problem here is that now you've unpacked
your APK expansion file, you've left all this
junk over the user's SDK card and the expansion
file is gone so what does Google Play do?
What every sane system would do, dude, your
file's gone, want 'em back?
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: So now instead of a gig or whatever
it was, you've got two gigs and you've got
some very unhappy users.
Unfortunately, the way this works is you have
to use your APK expansion file in place.
Now Dan's written a bunch of samples that
-- do you notice, by the way, every time we
talk about sample code, it starts "Dan's written,"
and every time it's something I did, it starts
"I was so drunk."
This is exactly why he's the senior member
of our team.
>>Dan Galpin: Because I'm a month older.
There we are.
>>Ian Lewis: That's true.
So what you want to do is if you have your
own binary blob reader, you have pack files
or whatever, go ahead and use that.
If you don't, we do have some samples that
show you how to use an APK expansion file
or even any type of zip file as a mountable
file system and that can actually make things
easier for you.
>>Dan Galpin: The thing is an APK file is
really just a zip file.
A lot of people are like, well, I can't put
it in my APK, so it's not going to work.
I'm like you can just put another zip file
on the drive and you can do exactly the same
thing.
In fact, a lot of people are doing this.
In fact, they figured out that when they're
using something like unity, which normally
pulls all of its resources out of the APK
file, all you have to do is point to unity
and say actually my APK file is actually the
second thing that I download and then all
of a sudden unity will pull all the files
out of that.
And there's actually a tool that someone has
made that takes all of those unity files and
pull them over to the second file.
So it's not hard.
But if you don't have it built into your tool,
I have a couple of things that you can look
at.
Look at the APK expansion file libraries,
there's actually a zip resource file that
I put down there.
There's a content provider example, so if
you really want to go all the way Android
and you want to store content that's referenced
using an asset content provider, it's actually
all there in sample code for you.
So no excuses, man, okay?
>>Ian Lewis: All right, we ready for seven?
>>Dan Galpin: We're ready for seven.
>>Ian Lewis: This is going to be so good.
>>Dan Galpin: Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
So one of the things that happens when you
sign up for Google Play is that you're actually
asked to look at some things like what you
should do and what you shouldn't do on Google
Play.
If you think about Google Play is it is this
ecosystem where OEMs and developers and carriers
all get together to make sure there's one
awesome place to find great stuff.
>>Ian Lewis: A lot of times we do sort of
envision in our heads Google Play is like
the old "Star Trek" when Spock would play
this three-dimensional game of chess except
instead of Spock, it's Andy, and that's actually
totally downplaying the complexity of the
system.
There's a lot of players in the system and
it all combines to give you 400 million devices
to sell to, but it does come with some restrictions.
>>Dan Galpin: And the real key thing is we
want to make sure you can publish once and
you don't have to go and hunt and to find
all sorts of places and rules and different
sets of rules to publish your apps, so here
are our rules and they get you to the largest
number of devices.
All right.
>>Ian Lewis: The three commandments.
>>Dan Galpin: The three commandments of Google
Play.
One, thou shalt have no payment providers
but Google Play.
This is basically pretty simple.
You're listing on our service.
Don't confuse users by having them input all
sorts of different information, sending them
to different places, billing them without
their knowledge.
We want one straightforward way that users
understand they're paying for content.
>>Ian Lewis: We would also like to be able
to continue paying for Google Play so that's
-- we do have a bit of a selfish motive here.
And these rules aren't --
>>Dan Galpin: We want carriers to keep putting
Google Play on our devices.
That's probably the most important thing.
>>Ian Lewis: Yeah.
So, sir, you in the back, with the golden
cap, put that away.
>>Ian Lewis: Two, thou shalt not upload an
app that downloads other apps.
Now, because the main goal of Google Play
is to be a place where people go to find content
and it's not a place to distribute your app
store.
If you want to distribute your app store,
distribute it somewhere else.
Android is an open platform, okay?
The second thing is if you're actually installing
other apps, it's a really bad user experience,
you'll find out.
So, yeah, don't do it, and it's a good way
to make sure things happen badly with our
enforcement team.
All right.
And then finally, thou shalt not bribe thy
customers for five-star reviews.
>>Ian Lewis: For that is hateful in my sight,
sayeth me.
>>Dan Galpin: That was good.
So don't provide incentives for specific review
scores.
Google Play will not feature an app that incentivizes
review scores, partially because it's hard
to tell what people actually think of your
game when they're being paid to rate it five
stars.
Besides, it's actually impossible for your
game to find out what score a particular user
gave you.
So promising to pay for a specific score is
kind of dishonest.
So at the same time we don't want to discourage
apps from asking for ratings.
The right way to ask for ratings is to be
upfront, honest and sincere.
Ask users for their candid feedback.
If you want to, you could incentivize your
user to leave a rating, just don't ask for
a specific rating.
You could also ask for a specific rating without
offering an incentive, that's within the letter
of the law, but not really the spirit.
The whole point of a review is to get honest
feedback so you can improve your game.
>>Ian Lewis: So here's some examples that
we pulled from actual games and simply, you
know, altered a little bit to protect the
innocent.
And so when we did this presentation for our
team, we got two major pieces of feedback.
One was the Australians thought that thing
six was racist.
And two was -- you don't even remember what
thing six was so we didn't -- you'll wake
-- the coffee will kick in in a little bit.
Two was we see these -- these example dialogue
boxes, but there's no real feedback is -- as
to which ones are good, which ones are bad
and how good and bad they are.
So I've enlisted my baby daughter to help
out.
"Thanks for playing, please take some time
to rate this game on Google Play.
We want to know what you think."
Baby daughter says, "Oh, Daddy, that's so
great!"
>>Dan Galpin: "Did you enjoy this game?
Rate it five stars!"
Whew.
>>Ian Lewis: Baby daughter says, "That's a
little sketchy, Daddy."
>>Dan Galpin: Even worse, "Having fun?
Your five-star rating helps us to keep this
game updated!"
Oh, sad daughter!
Or how about this, "Want more GalpinBux?
Rate this game five stars and get 100 GalpinBux
right away and all of your friends will think
you're cool!"
Bad!
So there's some shady characters out there
that will claim these rules don't apply to
them or they're not enforced or they have
some sort of arrangement with Google that
allows them to use a third-party payment processor.
This is not true.
Do not believe their lies.
All right?
So we are giving you the straight story here.
And that takes us to point 8.
>>Ian Lewis: Awesome.
In-app payments are unfortunately easy to
get wrong.
Now, our in-app payment system seems like
it should be relatively easy.
Okay.
Customer decides they are going to buy something,
they hit the big button, delivers the thing,
and the customer receives it and everything
is cool.
They are super happy.
>>Dan Galpin: Thanks, bro.
>>Ian Lewis: But what really happens is a
little bit like the FedEx scenario here, but
you are asleep.
Sometimes your app will be sleeping when this
message arrives.
In that case, normal real world -- okay.
Normal real world delivery companies have
a policy, right?
They are going to try to deliver and if there's
somebody home, like your roommate, they will
be like, oh, can you sign for this?
Yeah, totally.
And then later on your roommate gives you
the package and you're, like --
>>Dan Galpin: Thanks, bro.
>>Ian Lewis: Excellent.
But what if your roommate is this guy?
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: So here's what happens.
Very, very common in games because so many
games use native libraries.
Game is going to be written with a big game
piece and this little billing service piece
that you tacked on as an afterthought because
our documentation said that you had to.
There is big shared library that both of those
pieces are going to talk to.
And that is totally fine as long as you're
launching with the expected process.
Right?
So the user has clicked on your icon in a
launcher, launcher sends action main, game
starts.
It starts up the shared library.
Service starts.
Talks to the shared library, listens for billing
messages.
Billing message gets there.
It does whatever you do in the game to acknowledge
billing and fulfill it, and everybody is happy.
But sometimes things don't go as planned because
when the message gets there, your app is no
longer available.
Why?
Why would that happen?
It's conventional wisdom to think this is
because our billing process took way too long
and that's actually untrue.
Not because our billing process is lightning
fast, although it frequently is, but because
we actually just canceled the whole thing
after what is it?
45 seconds?
>>Dan Galpin: These are, for the most part
in your applications, these are synchronous
transactions.
>>Ian Lewis: Why is your app asleep?
The first culprit is Google Play itself.
In order to the in-app billing, we have to
launch Google Play.
Google Play is not maybe the slimmest service
in the world and, in general, games aren't
either.
So when two large processes start on the Android
device, the OS starts to freakout.
Like okay, one of these things has got to
go, right?
>>Dan Galpin: One of the things to note is
your application will get long memory and
it has the ability to eject stuff at this
point and try to keep itself alive.
But, you know, a lot of game developers don't
really want to do that.
They are like, life cycle, whatever, we will
let ourselves die.
That's what happens.
We go, you're the biggest thing going and
we can get rid of a lot of space to allow
Google Play to actually run.
>>Ian Lewis: Ironically enough, launching
the in-app billing kills your process, and
then when you come back from in-app billing,
your process should restart but you frequently
don't take care of that correctly.
This is a little unexpected.
But that aside, there's actually another really
good reason for your app to be asleep when
a billing message arrives.
I would like to illustrate this point with
a small shot of a portion of Dan's desk.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Lewis: A lot of people have multiple
devices.
And Google Play policies allow you to buy
something once and use it on multiple devices.
Customers love this.
I love this.
It's a great policy.
But what it means is if I bought something
on my phone, my tablet is going to get a billing
message.
And since my tablet probably isn't even on,
the app that's supposed to receive it is probably
asleep.
So what happens?
Well, of course you will wake up.
We need to deliver this thing.
So Google Play is going to try and wake you
up.
But it's not going to try to wake up your
whole app.
It just wakes up the service.
The problem is, when the service wakes up,
you haven't written it to initialize all of
the other code.
You wouldn't want to.
Right?
A lot of times initializing the shared library,
loads your resources.
You are doing a lot of expensive work.
If the shared library is not there -- and
by shared library, that's a catch-all for
your in-game message system, unity messages,
shared memory between yourselves and game.
Anything that's not persistent.
That will kill everything.
>>Dan Galpin: I want to make it clear that
I actually didn't put the fire effects in
this presentation, okay?
>>Ian Lewis: I thought you did.
>>Dan Galpin: Only one of them.
>>Ian Lewis: Then I got a little excited.
I want to be like Dan.
A lot of times people say that's not a problem,
right?
I read the documentation.
This isn't an issue.
You guys are reliable.
If I don't acknowledge your receipt, then
you're just going to keep calling me back,
right?
Which is somewhat true.
If you do not acknowledge a billing message,
we will keep calling you back until it gets
acknowledged.
Let's leave aside the fact that some developers
will acknowledge the billings message anyway
without successfully delivering it.
Those guys need to get their act together.
Waiting for our billing message to be re-sent
has two issues.
The first is, because we don't want to completely
spam the users device, we use exponential
back-off.
Since you have gotten yourself into a situation
where your app needs to be running in order
for the billing message to be received, you're
in a crap shoot here because the user has
to have launched your app in order for that
billing message to be received and the billing
messages are comings at a slower and slower
rate.
It's very, very unlikely that they are actually
going to have the app open at the correct
time.
Especially if they just closed it in frustration
because they think that you cheated them by
not delivering the goods that they just purchased.
But there's a second and more compelling reason
to be careful about this.
And that is, during this entire time that
we are essentially leaving post-it notes on
your door.
Tried to deliver, we'll be back tomorrow.
Tried to deliver, adult must sign.
That whole time the user has already been
billed.
So let me just emphasize that.
The user has already been billed.
We billed the user when we sent the first
acknowledgment.
Why?
Otherwise it would be trivial for an user
to buy something and then block your port
so you couldn't send an acknowledgment.
Then we would be like, oh, it never got delivered.
Meanwhile you are like, oh, I guess it got
fulfilled.
The user is, like, hee-hee-hee.
The user will see this show up on its credit
card.
If you don't fulfill it immediately, they
will think that you cheated them.
You sort of did unintentionally.
This turns into a support call for you.
Often a support call for us.
Overall a poor experience.
Be very, very --
>>Dan Galpin: Bad ratings.
That's the key thing.
Bad ratings keep your app from being featured.
>>Ian Lewis: Absolutely.
What should you do?
The right way to do this is to be reliable
for yourself.
We took care of reliably delivering this thing
all the way across the Internet through miles
and miles of fiber optic cables and harsh
vacuous space, the least you can do is reliably
deliver it from one piece of your app to the
other.
The right way to do this is persisting it.
When your service wakes up to receive a notification
from the billing, it should persist that to
some sort of storage.
I don't care if you want to use a file, SQLite,
or whatever, then send your in-game message
to say, they, go check your mailbox.
Your app will check that and see that the
message came in and deal with it.
If your app was sleeping at the time, then,
fine, you don't get the notification that
says, hey, go check persistent storage.
But the next time your app starts up, the
first thing do you is check for persistent
storage.
A purchase came in.
Congratulations, you have a hundred more Galpin
bucks or whatever it is you are giving away.
The user can immediately see that they did,
indeed, purchase and get value for the money
that they just spent.
>>Dan Galpin: Let's go quickly on to 9.
Let's take a quick talk about testing.
We have a lot of devices and the problem with
lots of devices is people are trying to figure
out, how do I test with this vast ecosystem
that we have out here.
But the truth is, most of this stuff is actually
really straightforward.
Input devices, there are not that many input
devices on Android and you should support
as many of them as you possibly can.
Form factor, it's pretty straightforward.
We don't actually have that many different
form factor styles in Android.
You have to support a series of aspect ratios
between 69 and 133.
And it's not the end of the world for most
titles if you started off the design of the
title to support that.
If you decided you will support one aspect
ratio from the beginning and then you are,
like, oh, my goodness, I am now going to Android
that I have to support four, essentially,
then this is going to be a rough transition
for you.
It's good to start off designing for that.
Even if you haven't designed for it, there
are things that you can do that are fairly
straightforward to make it look like you designed
for it.
OS version, that's pretty straightforward.
The OS versions don't differ all that much.
It's pretty easy to get.
Here we get to the hard stuff.
The driver stack and the GPU hardware.
There's kind of two things to look at.
One, of course, is -- this may be hard to
believe, there are sometimes bugs in drivers.
I'm sure none of you have ever experienced
this on any other devices, but it actually
happens.
GPU hardware differs.
Let's talk quickly about the most common GPUs
you will see in the Android world.
We have Adreno, PowerVR, Tegra, Mali, Vivante,
and Broadcom.
Many of you probably haven't heard of the
last two, but they are in many devices as
well.
All of them essentially work differently than
PowerVR.
So if you all go and say I just tested on
that second one, if you only test on the Galaxy
Nexus, if you only performance, profile and
optimize around the Galaxy Nexus, you will
be sad.
Because on PowerVR usually you get a lot of
performance by sorting things like by materials.
You pretty much want to ignore sorting things
by geometry, depth, and complexity.
On every one of these platforms, you get an
enormous performance boost by doing that.
you want to have your engine and renderer
to be able work both ways.
First of all, performance, there's that element.
Also we have several different texture compression
formats.
If you want the highest possible performance,
and all of these devices are ultimately fill
limited.
Then of course you want to use the best texture
compression possible.
So for your non-alpha textures that are actually
fairly light photographic, you can use ETC1
on every single one of these platforms.
But when you get into things that are using
alpha, then you're going to be stuck going
to one of the proprietary formats or using
a shader and 2EC1 textures which will slow
things down.
These are decisions you have to make as to
how optimal it is.
You want your game to be how necessary it
is to make these optimizations.
We actually support multiple APKs based upon
texture compression formats.
So you can have a separate APK with a separate
APK expansion file.
There are ways to tackle this problem.
And again, it may not be necessary for your
title.
The thing to do is make sure you have one
of at least four of these, probably the top
four as they represent the largest majority
of devices out there to test on.
And that's just the most important thing.
If you are doing a 3D game -- if you're doing
a 2G game, chances are you may not notice.
But if you are doing a 3D game, it's important
to make sure that you work with these different
drivers.
>>Ian Lewis: Excellent.
Thing 10, I took a little bit about play listings.
So let's say that you have done everything
that we have asked.
You've got a great game, great ratings.
You didn't screw up the in-app billing.
You didn't do anything shady with your permissions
and we totally want to feature you.
One problem.
We need to actually get you into the store.
And where a lot of people end up having problems
is on the listing itself.
Now, it may not be obvious but when you upload
the gigantic graphic that we use on our web
site, you are also actually uploading the
little itty-bitty graphic that we use on the
device.
>>Dan Galpin: It looks gruesome in both modes.
>>Ian Lewis: It really does.
We chose this graphic, A, because the game
is featured this week.
B, because it does have a serious problem
in that the contrast here isn't really great
enough for you to be able to read the title
Shane Reaction when that thing gets shrunk
down to about an inch across.
What I will usually tell people to do is attach
this to, like, Gmail or something that does
a thumbnail preview.
Get up from your desk, walk about six feet
back, look at it on your web browser and ask
yourself, can you still read the title?
Does it still look good?
If it doesn't, then it's not going to look
good on a very small form factor device.
So be careful to give yourself enough contrast.
Use a large enough area for the title.
And be a little careful of subtitles.
You can see for instance on Real Soccer, although
they did a great job of making the RS and
the Real Soccer big enough to read --
>>Dan Galpin: Dude.
>>Ian Lewis: Oh, wow.
>>Dan Galpin: That was a software update that
came right in the middle of our presentation.
>>Ian Lewis: Thanks Google.
All right.
So, yeah, when you look at that on the small
device, the subtitle gets nearly lost.
We usually tell people that if you're using
about 50% of the surface area of your graphic
for your logo, that's probably going to show
up okay.
If you are using less than that, you will
want to do some serious testing to make sure
that it's not going to become Illegible when
it gets tiny.
Speaking of feature graphic, sometimes people
omit them entirely.
Like this famous developer, who apparently
knows nothing about Android.
At least a few people recognize this game.
So the problem with this now is that since
he didn't upload a web feature graphic, we
are actually unable to feature the game at
all because we don't have anything to put
in that space.
You might say, oh, can't you guys use some
other graphic, wouldn't that be smart?
Sure, but you know how software works.
We totally don't have that pipeline.
Some day we will, maybe.
But not today.
>>Dan Galpin: Besides, would you want to choose
one of these random screen shots?
It doesn't make any sense.
>>Ian Lewis: If you don't have a graphic here
on your web store listing, you're not going
to get featured.
You're also not going to get featured if your
description is terrible or if you use this
space to do some key word spamming or if you've
got, all capitals, super excited stuff.
Or if you say things like now the hit game
on this other platform finally comes to Android
because it sucks less or something, you know.
[ Laughter ]
>>Dan Galpin: The feature team loves that.
>>Ian Lewis: By the way, if you've got a screen
shot here or more commonly a game play video
that ends with a spinning shot of some other
device with a now available on some other
store, that's sort of a party foul.
You don't want to do that.
We won't feature you.
We will get on the phone, can you upload a
different video.
But save us both some time and don't do that.
>>Dan Galpin: Another thing to note here.
There are rules against spamming and key word
spam in here.
So you should actually go through the Google
Play terms of service because one thing you
don't want to do is say, if you really liked
blah game and blah game, and blah game, you
should like our clone of it.
First of all, it looks kind of awful to do
that.
And second of all, it is key word spam as
far as our team is concerned.
And it can actually get your game, believe
it or not, suspended.
So it's actually a very serious rule.
They don't want people to try to leverage
other games' key words.
>>Ian Lewis: The other thing about this description
is, although we don't want you to key word
spam or use other service optimization techniques,
there are an optimization that will boost
you in the search ratings.
That is to make sure that your description
is localized.
If your description is localized into the
users language, then that description will
appear higher on search results compared to
similarly-ranked queries that are not localized.
People say what should I localize into?
And the most common response is going to be
EFIGS-CJK.
English, French, Italian, German, Spanish,
Japanese, Italian, Korean.
But if I had to pick two of these, the first
is English because, you know, we're white
dudes.
But second if you can only pick one non-English
language, you will probably best -- now, of
course, this isn't advice that is universally
applicable, you would be better off with Korean
because Korea loves Android.
It's a huge, huge market for Android products
and Android games.
So you go there and then maybe Japanese.
>>Dan Galpin: Japan is pretty awesome.
It depends on the title whether it is culturally
important.
Most importantly, point 11.
>>Ian Lewis: Because it goes to 11.
>>Dan Galpin: Make a great game.
I know, I know.
So obviously as we said before, editorial
process.
Ultimately, making awesome games is the way
to get featured.
But if you do all of those other things, you're
going to not get featured.
So we've told you what not to do and now go
out, make awesome games.
Don't let these things block your games from
getting featured.
We wanted to thank you for coming.
We are out of time.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Dan Galpin: We actually don't have time
for Q&E.
Ian and I will hang out after the session
a and answer your questions individually.
Thank you all for coming to ten things Android
game developers should know.
>>Ian Lewis: Don't forget to catch our YouTube
show every Friday 2 p.m.
It gives us an excuse to drink beer and you
information for games we are looking at featuring
and why or why not they might not pass our
review process.